okay chair the meeting is now life on
YouTube thank you and welcome everyone
to this meeting the public protection
committee and welcome back we've not met
for some time so it's good that we've
now got a way of doing this
virtually we'll just run through the
agenda as it is so just to note the
attendances apologists from councillor
Churchill and councillor Bunton this
afternoon we're still that we remain
Quaritch so we've known issues issues
there just can we agree the minutes from
the 21st of January and the 20th of
February please reach oh thank you for
that thank you
so item 3 on the agenda this afternoon
is the application for the renewal of a
sex establishment license that Tatars in
Altrincham and I am Joanne I don't know
which of you is doing this item this
afternoon both muted at the moment can
you keep hello it's Joanne can you hear
me hi Joanne yeah I'll be doing the
presentation Thank You mr. mr. Don
welcome to the meeting the staff this
afternoon I think you've been to this
committee before so you you sort of know
how the how the meeting will run this
afternoon if you have any questions at
all before we start no none of them all
right thank you
and so our licensing manager will just
outline the application in front of us
this afternoon my colleagues may have
some questions for her and then there'll
be an opportunity for you to speak okay
thank you carry on thank you thank you
chair members of the subcommittee on the
23rd of November 1982 the council
adopted chairs or three of the local
government miscellaneous provisions act
1982
to gave power to the council to regulate
snack shops and sex cinemas in its area
this power was extended to the
regulation of sexual entertainment
venues in 2011 when the council adopted
section 27 of the policing and Crime Act
2009 the same time the council adopted a
policy on how it would deal with such
application and what factors it would
consider when determining them a copy of
the policy is attached to the report
before the subcommittee today on the
28th of February at 2020 prism bistro
limited submitted an application for
renewal of the sex establishment license
it holds the premises known as Tottie's
which is a lap-dancing bar located on
the causeway offering him the
application was advertised by way of
noticed on the premises and according to
the countless application procedure
another results licensing section with
the and objection to the use of the
premises as a sexual entertainment venue
on the ground that is located in an area
which is frequented by children
legislation provides a number of
discretionary grounds for refusal of a
sec establishment license subcommittee
may refuse a license if it considers the
applicant and or the layout character
and condition of the premises to be
unsuitable in this case has been no
evidence or suggestion that either the
applicant or the premises is unsuitable
to hold a license the subcommittee may
review the license if it considers at
the number of sex establishments and the
relevant mortality exceeds the number it
considers necessary currently the
council doesn't restrict the number of
sex establishments which it will allow
in any particular area
finally the subcommittee may refuse a
license if it believes that the
character of the relevant locality makes
it unsuitable as the objection is made
on the grounds that the location of the
premise isn't suitable this is the
reason this mess has been brought before
the subcommittee for determination
subcommittees asked to consider the
report the objection has been received
and the council's policy and decide
either to renew the establishment
license or to refuse to renew the
license and that concludes my
presentation and chair unless you've got
an applicator any questions for me at
this stage thank you do any of my and
committee colleagues have any questions
for Geron at this day
now um mr. Dodd Larssen opportunity now
if you just want to talk us through the
application please and any anything you
want is to be aware of
okay well the premises are though case
on the first floor it is basically a
loading bay area at the back we don't
open until 8 o'clock and evening
therefore the quandary about children
translates in through that area I'm a
little there a lot so obviously I've
been there 20 years and I've not come
across you know group the children out
there at that time I'm okay for nothing
thank you and I don't know if any of my
my colleagues have got any any relevant
questions at this point for mr. Dodd
councillor Wilson in your muted yep
sorry the it wasn't a question for mr.
Dodd it's just the in the photocopy of
the of the complaint the ends of the
sentences appear to be cut off so they
can't read the end of the lines again
okay I don't think it makes me I don't
think it makes a material difference
anyway is a short sentence can we just
read it out please
yeah please yeah luckily nothing can you
do your me to do it I can do it do you
see I'll counselor yes right it says
dear Jade I can't say that I am happy
with this establishment in the centre of
altering and namely as it is well on the
way home for girls from altering and
grammar school and the rest
grammar school and boys from the boys
drum school I realize that the owners
will say that they do not admit children
but as I said years ago to licensing
these children are nothing if not
unsurprising I would be glad to see this
application refused and that's it and I
think that we know as Joanna said that
there's no there's no evidence here has
this ever been an issue before I mean
have to say you know the open air
wouldn't suggest that every time when
school children would be going in this
has been an issue in the past in the
licensing team that there's never been
any issues to the application any other
questions at all I just wanted to make
the point I think I mean I've been
passed there a few times school times
any other times and it doesn't seem to
be on the actual path for school traffic
source peak I don't know whether there's
be ever been any actual complaint or
such you know but it's very clear in the
reports that one's written that there's
not been any complaints that we need to
take into consideration here thank you
mr. Dodd we just have to go it gets a
bit technical when we're in this
scenario is we just have to go into a
break room and have a quick discussion
and then come back so we will all leave
and then we will all come back is there
anything else you want to add at all
before we do that no the only thing I
want to decide concept council Java is
the license actually was still running
one week load for we closed down because
of the lockdown so I'd like the license
obviously to renew when I opened
probably sometime in August
thank you.thank right removals okay I'm
just